heute geht es um ein Thema das mich
ziemlich sauer macht am liebsten
sprechen wir hier auf Dr Watson ja über
coole Pläne für die Zukunft es gibt aber
auch eine Entwicklung die wir euch nicht
verschweigen können und das ist Anti
Obdachlosen Architektur heute geht es um
menschenfeindliches Design um
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner zweiter
Klasse und darum wie wir gerade
Obdachlose aus unseren Städten
vertreiben
die gesamte EU will bis 2030 die
Obdachlosigkeit in Europa beseitigen
vielleicht eine unglückliche Wortwahl
aber die Idee klingt ja erstmal gut
steigende Wohnungspreise niedrige Löhne
in den letzten 10 Jahren ist die
Obdachlosigkeit in Europa um 70%
gestiegen Zeit also das etwas passiert
aber was jetzt gerade gemacht wird ist
ziemlich umstritten überall wo viele
Menschen sind gibt es immer mehr von
diesen Bänken hier und das aus einem
Grund hier soll niemand schlafen das
nennt man Defensive Architektur überall
werden Sitzflächen oder Wind und
wettergeschützte öffentliche Orte
umgebaut um ungemütlich zu sein dort
sein ist okay nur eben nicht zu lange
und auch nicht aus dem falschen Gründen
aber warum wird das gemacht
die Theorie hinter Defensive Architektur
nennt sich Crime Prevention für
environmental Design kurz CPT ID und wie
dieser griffige Name schon sagt geht es
dabei darum Verbrechen zu verhindern und
zwar durch das Design unserer Umgebung
als Beispiel wird hier gerne die Theorie
des gebrochenen Fensters genannt kaputte
Fenster stehen laut Kriminologie für
Verbrechen und antisoziales Verhalten so
erzeugen sie eine Umgebung in der mehr
von diesen Dingen passieren ergo sollten
wir eine Umgebung gestalten die das
Gegenteil tut soziales Verhalten fördert
und Verbrechen verhindert und dazu
gehören nicht zuletzt auch weniger
kaputte Fenster und oft auch weniger
Menschen die auf der Straße leben und
hier schon mal direkt meine eigene
Meinung ein Kommentar von mir dass sie
Obdachlose sind die oft nicht für Ihre
Situation können und denen man helfen
sollte mit kaputten Fenstern
gleichgesetzt und damit verunmenschlicht
werden das kotzt mich schon richtig an
okay
zurück zu den Fakten wie gut CPT
funktioniert ist umstritten eine sehr
bekannte aber leider schon ältere
meterstudie hat herausgefunden dass
Raubdelikte in den USA durch CPT
zwischen 30 und 80 Prozent
zurückgegangen sind das ist erstmal eine
riesige Spanne die es schwierig macht
ein finales Urteil zu fällen aber ganz
wichtig CPT umfasst viel mehr als nur
defensive Architektur die Anti
Obdachlosen Architektur an sich steht
weitaus mehr in der Kritik und dazu
kommen wir auch gleich noch wir haben
für dieses Video hier unzählige Stunden
in Recherche schreiben und
Postproduktion investiert um auf diese
Ungerechtigkeit aufmerksam zu machen
dabei haben wir natürlich wie auch bei
anderen Videos einiges an Zeit an
unseren Schreibtischen verbracht viele
von euch kennen das bestimmt auch wenn
man an einem spannenden Projekt arbeitet
oder eine Hausarbeit schreibt oder
einfach mal wieder eine Runde zockt
können schnell ein paar Stunden vergehen
die WHO warnt aber schon seit Jahren das
zu wenig Bewegung und dauerhaftes sitzen
das Risiko für Typ 2 Diabetes
Herzerkrankungen und sogar Depressionen
erhöht deshalb haben wir uns mit Flexi
Spot zusammengetan die dieses Video hier
gerne unterstützen wollten schon seit
einigen Jahren nutzen wir hier im Büro
nämlich höhenverstellbare Schreibtische
weil es einfach viel gesünder ist nicht
den ganzen Tag zu sitzen mit den
Schreibtischen von Flexi Sport könnt ihr
jederzeit einfach in eine andere Etage
gehen und zwischen Stehen und Sitzen
wechseln egal ob beim Arbeiten beim
zocken oder beim dr Watson Videos gucken
das trägt dazu bei das Risiko von den
eben genannten Gesundheitsproblemen zu
verringern und steigert auch eure
Energie und Konzentration das Holz für
die Schreibtische kommt und noch dazu
aus nachhaltig angelegten Wäldern und
ist gut recycelt war wenn auch ihr etwas
mehr Bewegung in Euren Alltag bringen
wollt und einen Flexi Spot Schreibtisch
mal selbst ausprobieren möchte dann
klickt den ersten Link unten in der
Beschreibung in den nächsten Tagen
gibt's da noch mal dicke Rabatte und
sogar kostenlosen Versand zusätzlich
habt ihr 60 Tage Rückgaberecht und bis
zu 10 Jahre Garantie in diesem Sinne
danke an Flexi Sport und jetzt zurück
zum Thema für defensive Architektur wird
außerdem argumentiert dass ein
Ausschluss aus dem öffentlichen Raum
vielleicht den nötigen Anstoß gibt sein
Leben wieder in den Griff zu bekommen
hierzu konnten wir aber absolut keine
stichhaltigen zahlen keine Beweise oder
irgendwelche seriösen Quellen finden die
dieses Argument untermauern und das sind
übrigens noch die wohlwollenden
Argumente die Freien Wähler wollen in
Köln mit Hilfe von solchen Design die
Verwahrlosung der Innenstadt stoppen bis
die Regierung einen besseren Plan hat
sagen sie zumindest was sie damit aber
auch in Kauf nehmen und die Maßnahmen
treffen uns alle nehmen wir zum Beispiel
mal die Banker auf den man schlecht und
nur kurz sitzen kann klar hier kann
niemand sein zu Hause aufschlagen und
vielleicht sorgt das irgendwie für eine
sichere Umgebung aber genauso wenig kann
sich eine erschöpfte alte Schwangere
oder behinderte Person dort ausruhen
sagen Kritiker und ich persönlich finde
auch sowas einfach hässlich aus Städte
könnten so schön sein der zweite große
Punkt ist dass wir ein Problem so ja
wegschieben die vielschichtigen so zu
ökonomischen Gründe weswegen man
obdachlos werden kann werden nicht durch
betonstachel bekämpft die Menschen
werden gezwungen eben woanders obdachlos
zu sein aber das löst das eigentliche
Problem nicht ja es gibt Einrichtungen
in denen Obdachlose einen Schlafplatz
finden können die Kapazität Sicherheit
und der allgemeine Zustand diese Heime
stehen aber deutschlandweit in der
Kritik
das alles mal aus dem vor ist es nicht
so ganz klar ob diese Maßnahmen wirklich
nur aus Sicherheitsgründen gemacht
werden es gibt wenig Studien zu dem
Thema aber eine die viel zitiert wird
sieht andere Gründe hinter Defensive
Architektur nämlich wirtschaftliche
Interessen Investoren könnten
abgeschreckt sein und wenn eine Stadt
will das Geld in das Bauen investiert
wird dann macht sie die Umgebung so
schön wie möglich für die Investoren
nicht für die Obdachlosen
manche Kritiker gehen sogar noch weiter
und sagen dass CPT generell ein Angriff
auf die Demokratie ist öffentliche
Plätze werden durch immer weitere
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen weniger öffentlich
anders sein wird vertrieben und so wird
gewollt oder ungewollt eine homogene
Gesellschaft geschaffen die ohnehin
schon ausgeschlossene Menschen
wegschieben
also fassen wir das alles mal zusammen
ob Defensive Architektur funktioniert
wissen wir nicht zumindest mit anderen
Maßnahmen zusammen lässt sich eine
positive Entwicklung in puncto
Verbrechen sehen was davon die
Obdachlosigkeit betrifft können wir eine
aktuellem Stand aber leider nicht sagen
der kostennutzenfaktor von Anti
Obdachlosen Architektur ist also
ungeklärt genauso die eigentliche
Motivation dahinter was aber ziemlich
schlüssig ist wir lösen so Symptome aber
keine Ursachen denn eigentlich ist das
Problem ja ein ganz anderes und zwar
nicht dass Menschen auf der Straße leben
sondern dass sie keine Wohnung haben das
hat auch Finnland erkannt und deswegen
gibt es dort jetzt eine posing
first-maßnahme das heißt Obdachlosen
wird kein Platz in einer Unterkunft
sondern schnellstmöglich eine eigene
Wohnung vermittelt und der Gedanke
dahinter klingt logisch erst wenn man
quasi den Dauerstress einer
Obdachlosigkeit beendet hat dann hat man
Zeit ein Problem nach dem anderen
anzugehen ohne nebenbei einen
Schlafplatz für die Nacht zu suchen aber
das ist ein Thema für ein anderes Video
liebe leute bleibt neugierig und danke
fürs zuschauen